Now that we have completed our light switch in this part of our tutorial we're going to talk about how we can extend our light switch because right now the light switch is usable but it's usable in some very very finite situations and it'd be nice if we could extend this light switch in order to make it make sense to control multiple lights and we can actually do that by switching up our blueprint logic and adding the following node,
a for each loop. What a for each loop does is it iterates through an array or a collection of items and then can do something or spit out each one of those items so you can get some more information about it.
We're also going to need to go and look at our variable light which is remember our BP activatable. I'm going to need to change that from a singleton and to an array variable so that we can again have multiple lights that are controlled by the same light switch.
Now I would like everybody to pause right here, take the next few minutes, see if you can figure this out for yourselves and then we'll get started with the answer here in just a second.
All right now that you have had a chance to try and create this on your own let's take a look at this example and rebuild this for anybody that might be struggling.
So in our event use object, all we need to do is just actually add our for each loop there right before is valid check and our light.
We need to convert that to a variable or I should say we need to convert our light variable to an array and then inside of our actual level will need to also add the lights that we want this to control.
So let's pop over here to unreal and we're going to grab this which is our light switch so I'm going to hit control E that's going to open up this blueprint check this out was pretty easy to do so first off under our event use object we're going to add our for each.
There's our for each loop.
There we go. So we're going to plug the execution in here.
And then our loop body is going to come in like so.
And the other thing that we have to do is we need to come to this light here, and we're going to come to this variable, and we're going to make this an array, and it's going to say we have some issues, and all we have to do here is just hold alt and break that.
And then what we need to do is come here and plug the light into an array. And again, the for each loop node is going to take this array right here, and it's going to iterate over however many items are in here.
So if we have two items in here, it's going to do it twice if we have 16 it's going to do it 16 times so we do we access each item by accessing this array element out right here so we plug this in like so, and in like so we are going to be able to compile and save this.
So let's close that down. And now what's going to happen is you can see here we have our lights let me just grab a couple lights here, like so.
And then we're going to say, one, two and three, and then we can go one, two, and three. Now let's go ahead and play this. And we're going to come over here and just oops. There we go.
Turn those three on turn them off right there. Boom. All right. So, again, just to recap, all we did is we intercepted our event use object with our for each loop, we converted our light reference to the array variable types so we could have multiple lights.
And then we connected the array element to our input object and our target object of our activate object blueprint interface.